for this audition is it even more
intimidating to submit for this movie
considering your Transformers fan not
really yeah it actually made it made me
want to do really to do better right I
was like I'll just form is awesome like
I didn't really think about like the
pressure of I was like oh cool yeah
let's I'm in Philly all I think about is
the pressure I need to take a cue from
you and just relax you're my thanks show
I know I'm also because memo in this
he's actually not chill he's a little
nervous and unerring goofy but that's
why we love him
so memos room because I also read that
you have a lot of things that you like
that he likes so did you get to pick any
of the posters or any of the little
details there we we met halfway like
yellow I want some basketball posters
and they were like I it has to be Larry
Bird though that's appropriate yeah it
makes sense that most fundamentally
sound
I liked the the movie poster so you had
nothing to do with the thing no but when
I saw I was like dude awesome person
needed to be there especially for a
movie that takes place in the 80s
I've actually this is like the second
movie I have that poster on my wall
really mm-hmm
what's the other one it's called
Brisbane bear like this comedy Briggs me
Bear is so good and I feel like not
enough people out there still talking
about that I should do it it's thank you
it's a good movie really I enjoyed
making it
I can we had the thing there too you can
totally tell everyone looked like they
enjoyed making that Rachel and this one
as well and I have to bring up one of my
favorite scenes in this movie which is
the revenge scene so while you're
shooting that do you have any idea what
you're looking at whatsoever or is it
kind of just Travis saying you know
bumblebee is doing this this and that
and you got to imagine whatever you can
I'm glad you brought this one up cuz I
feel like that was a hardest scene for
me to shoot for when I was like at four
in the morning so I was very delirious
and - Travis is like I look over there
and do the thing and then I'm doing
something dumb horrible take and then
Travis just comes out it's like uh yeah
do more you got to get a not bad so that
was a fun one I was watching the b-roll
for that and it's just the two of you
standing
they're looking at nothing and you're
really going for it you really dig into
his goofy excited vibe dude Travis was
like yo you gotta you gotta jump like
this I'm like yeah you sure all right
but no that's what had me in tears I was
laughing it's awesome yeah really
appreciated that also as a big
Transformers fan and just being part of
movies that aren't just entertainment
experiences but movies that have that
extra level that means something to
someone whether we're talking about love
Simon where it can affect someone for
their life or something like this where
it's about bringing a fandom together in
a new way what does it mean to you to be
part of these movies that are making
such a big impact right now you know
that's something as an actor that I hope
to do with all of my work you know
besides making something that's very
entertaining I hope that that might work
or the work that I'm a part of can speak
to people in a way that that changes
people's lives for the better even if
it's just incremental even if it just
warms your heart to learn more or if it
helps you cope with with you know
growing up from a teenager and feeling a
little different
both those boxes this year I was sitting
next to another Collider employee that
everybody knows well and he's a big
transformers fan I was not so much and
for the first time in years the two of
us were sitting there and enjoying
transformers together that's awesome you
see movies that bring people together
that's what I like
you